- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
This is how we greet people
in my part of the world.
And it means peace
be upon you all.
Two days ago, Judy
invited us for dinner
at her home, us and all
the rest of the Fellows.
And she shared with
us photos and memories
from her grandparents' and her
husband's grandparents' exodus
from Europe after World War II.
The stories that she
shared reminded me--
the stories of displacement
that she shared
reminded me-- of my own
father's displacement
and his own stories.
We actually-- the
Dajani family--
comes from Jerusalem
and Palestine.
We've been there for
at least 500 years.
And this is the tombstone
of one of my ancestors,
who was born in 1459.
And that's a shield of
armor for our family.
And that's a group photo of the
extended family back in 1940s.
And this is our compound,
the Dajani compound.
We were the ancient--
we're the caretakers of one of
the ancient gates of Jerusalem
from the ancient city.
But unfortunately,
in 1948, Zionists
took over my family home.
And my father and his family had
to flee to Lebanon at that time
and haven't been
able to go back.
They carry with them the photos,
the keys for their homes.
And they're not alone.
There were only 700,000
people who flee then.
So I felt so much compatibility
with Judy's story.
And it made me reflect
on displacement
and what does it mean to us.
And I think that
feeling of displacement,
it pushes me to explore,
what does belonging mean?
And I think through a
different series of events,
it's what ended with me
here today in front of you,
to share my journey
and my story.
And not to spare you
anything from Jerusalem,
I brought with me
today some sweets.
So this is a shop, a sweet
shop that was established
in Jerusalem in the 1860s.
It's called Zalatimo.
Luckily, they opened a shop
in Jordan, so I was in Jordan
and I brought them with me.
So I hope you'll enjoy
them after the talk.
So my talk is
entitled Five Scarves.
And I say five scarves,
what I mean is five hats.
You know, the metaphor, you wear
a hat, you wear multiple hats.
You have different
careers or different roles
you play in life.
So I don't wear
hats, I wear a scarf.
So that's why I'm going to
tell you the five scarves I
wear as I go through my talk.
My talk is divided
into three parts.
Part one will be how the
starred story started.
Part two, the main
theme of the book.
And then part three,
the unanswered questions
that I hope you will help
me answer during our Q&A.
As human beings,
we enjoy stories.
We love to listen to stories.
And I think this is
part of our evolution.
So through ancient
history, as humans evolved,
probably there were
two groups of people.
A group of people
that sat around
the fire and read
stories, and another
did not sit around
telling stories.
They were more serious.
And they frowned upon those
who sat around reading stories.
And you can imagine which one
of those groups survived today.
It's the storytellers.
So apparently, storytelling
is essential for our survival
as a species to cope
with this world.
So in the spirit
of evolution, I'm
going to share with you my
story and how it brought me here
to Radcliffe.
So my journey starts
four decades ago.
I come from a family of eight
girls and I'm the eldest.
And we had a boy in the end,
but there's a 20 year difference
between him and I. So I
don't consider he's part
of the family at this point.
We grew up, there
was no TV by choice.
And so, we read a lot.
We read different
stories and novels.
And we read National Geographic
and Scientific American.
And we actually did a
lot of play rolling--
role playing, to the
extent that sometimes we
mistook the book for real life.
Many, many times.
We're eight girls,
different ages, sizes.
So we could do that.
And we also had many
debates and discussions
at home, between us-- the
girls-- and with my parents,
both my mother and father.
And this is what fostered in
us curiosity, asking questions,
and not letting ourselves to
be comfortable with anything
that was not less than logical
in the way we approach things.
I also learned three
lessons in that period
of my life, which stemmed from
my upbringing, my culture,
and my religion.
And those were one, that
you have a responsibility
towards your community.
You have to do something
for your community.
You can't just enjoy
life by yourself.
And the second lesson
is that we have to-- we
are responsible for our
time, to do something good
with our time.
And not to spend
it without meaning.
The third lesson was, it
doesn't matter if you succeed.
What matters is that you try.
That's the important thing.
So those lessons are what I
carried along with me in life
and helped me in what
I did eventually.
Now, in Jordan, if your
father is a physician,
you go and study medicine.
It's expected of you.
And I think, to a certain
extent, it is in many cultures.
So my father was a
physician, and therefore, I
was going to study medicine.
After I went into my
first year at college,
I decided I don't want to do
medicine, because I was scared.
I was scared of making a mistake
and killing someone by mistake.
And so, I thought,
you know what?
I'm going to be a
biologist, a scientist.
And if I make a mistake it will
be with mice or worms or flies.
And I could sleep if I
made a mistake with them.
And even as a
scientist, I could still
serve humanity
through my research,
through discovering the
reasons behind disease,
how proteins communicate,
how cells talk to each other.
So I studied biology and I
wanted to be a scientist.
Now, when you choose to study
something because you love it,
you excel in it, and
work becomes play.
Einstein said, choose
the easiest path.
That way you enjoy every day
and every day is a play day.
And actually I chose
biology because to me,
it was the easiest.
And I love it.
And to me, everyday
is a play day.
I don't consider
my work as work.
I also graduated from college
and then I went and did
my master's.
But in Jordan, there's no PhD
programs back in the 1980s.
And so, there was
no internet, either.
So if you wanted
to study abroad,
you'd have to send a letter
and wait for three weeks
and send another letter
and wait for three weeks.
And you didn't know what were
the ranges of scholarships
available.
So I was not able to go, because
I didn't get a scholarship.
I actually got accepted
at Cambridge University
eventually, but I didn't
have the financial money
to actually go there.
And by then, I was married
and I had one child.
And my advisor then at
Cambridge University told me,
you can't come and do
your PhD with one child.
Later on, I did it with
four, but he doesn't know.
So the first scarf that I
like to say proudly I wear
is the one that I am a
mother of four children.
And so, I like to
wear my scarf that I'm
the mother of four children.
Now, they're all
grown up, of course.
This is a picture
a long time ago.
Now, meanwhile, since I
couldn't become a scientist,
I became a teacher.
So everybody who studies
science in Jordan,
if you're not academic,
you become a teacher.
So I was a teacher for 10 years.
And I taught elementary school,
high school, from grade 1
to grade 12, I taught biology,
science in English and Arabic.
All different types of programs.
And I think that
period of my life
helped me understand what are
the challenges that children
face in their everyday lives.
What are the challenges
that teachers
face in their everyday life.
And how important the
job of the teacher.
And how we, as a community,
don't give enough importance
for the teacher.
And I always say if I ever
become a minister of education,
the first thing I
will do is to make
it compulsory for every college
graduate to teach for one year.
It's like military obligation.
You have to do that.
And the reason is
if they do it, they
realize how difficult
and important
is the job and the
role of the teacher,
because he or she are bringing
up the next generation.
Well, as I was
teaching, my husband
saw an ad in the newspaper
that the Fulbright
was offering PhD programs.
And so he said, Rana,
there's your chance.
Because my dream is
still to be a scientist.
So I actually, at the age of
30, took my exams all over again
and wrote essays all over again.
And I was called for
an interview the day
before my last daughter was due.
And I told them, but
tomorrow's my due date.
And they said, oh,
if you have the baby,
you can call us from
your hospital bed.
I didn't have the baby.
And the baby is actually
sitting here in front,
[? Zara, ?] she's my last one.
And I went to the interview.
I made the interview,
I got a scholarship.
And now, the decision
was, what do we do?
This is a family, a full
family of four kids from zero
to 10 years old.
And we were thinking,
what do we do?
Do I take the kids and go?
Does my husband keep the kids
in Jordan, I go by myself?
This is a PhD in
molecular biology,
it's a five year commitment.
And at that point
my husband, who
was a Lieutenant Colonel in
the Air Force, he said, Rana,
I'm going to resign.
So he resigned so that we could
keep the whole family together.
And we went as one
unit to the US,
so that we could
take care of the kids
together, make
sure that they had
a healthy home with both parents
there to take care of them.
So my husband has been
my mentor and my friend
and supporting me in
everything I do all along.
So I moved to the states.
First of all, I made it
very clear to my advisor
that my family is as
important as my research.
And if push comes to
shove, my kids come first.
So I always left at five, I
never came in on weekends.
And yet, I graduated
similar to my peers who
didn't have kids,
who were single,
who stayed all night in
the lab and on weekends.
So it's about time
management, knowing
how to do things
in the right way,
and setting your
priorities right.
And at home, actually my kids--
I trained them.
They did all the chores.
They did all the dinners.
Many times, if I had an
exam, I would come home
to find a six course dinner done
by my son, not my daughters.
Or a pie coming out of the
oven, very hot because I
had an exam or something.
And not just that, I actually
involved them in my work.
So every time I'd
go home and share
my experiments and my
results, and they'd
come up with hypotheses.
So when Mama was late, she
was testing their hypotheses.
So they were really excited.
And they made friends
with all my mice.
And of course, I was not allowed
to kill them until after--
I had to beg them that I had to
do it and I would explain why.
And actually, they all
have acknowledgments
in my publications for
being part of my research.
But that led to them being
immune to anything scientific.
So none of them went
to science at all.
They're all into the humanities.
They've had enough growing
up with being a scientist.
And this is them
celebrating with me.
They put me this
big card that I just
won a PhD, as if you win it.
You know, it's not
that we worked hard.
So then, after that we,
went back to Jordan.
And in Jordan, I started
at the University my work.
At the same time,
when you change
from one country to one
country or from one culture
to another culture, you
realize that there's
something different.
Things that you didn't notice
before you notice again,
either bad or good.
And that's when I noticed that
children in Jordan don't read,
don't read for pleasure.
So they read for education, they
read for religious purposes.
But when you speak about
reading for pleasure--
under the covers, you can't
wait to finish the story--
that kind of reading.
And that kind of reading
is very, very important,
because when you
read for pleasure,
this boosts your
imagination, your creativity.
You gain vocabulary.
And this vocabulary helps
you express yourself better
and you become less violent.
You'll learn about
other cultures.
So this develops your empathy
to understand others, listen
to others, and communicate
better with others.
And you become more
confident, because you
draw from the heroes you
read about the courage
to make a difference
in your own life.
So reading for pleasure
is very, very important.
And I was looking in--
especially like in Jordan
and Arab countries--
Islam is the majority religion.
And the first word
of the Quran is read.
So to me, the question is, why
don't we read for pleasure?
And I did some research
and I found out
that the reason we
don't read for pleasure
is because we
don't love to read.
There's no passion.
There's no-- this burning need
and desire that I want to read.
And also I did some research
to try to understand, how do we
plant that love of reading?
How do we make
people love to read?
And I found out, although
many people thought
it was because they
don't have enough books,
I found out that was
not the main reason.
The main reason that
children don't love to read
is because their parents
don't read aloud to them
when they're very young.
You should read to
your child as early
as when the mother is
pregnant, because what
happens in the
brain of the child,
there becomes a connection
between the feeling
of security, happiness,
and comfort with reading.
So you grow up, you want to be
a reader because it gives you
this good sense, the sense
of happiness, security
that you don't know
where it comes from.
So I found the solution to
make children love to read.
So what did I do at that time?
I mean, I could--
it's impossible to go around
and tell every parent,
you have to read aloud
to your children.
That's too much.
And even if I told the
government to pass a law,
that doesn't mean they're
going to follow the law.
So I felt this huge
responsibility.
And I thought, you know what?
I'm going to collect together
the children in my neighborhood
and read aloud to them.
And that's what we did.
It was a family project.
My husband and
children were involved.
And we started
reading in the mosque,
because it's in
every neighborhood.
And we thought, why not?
It's clean.
It's got a carpet.
It's got a bathroom.
And the first time we
announced that there's
going to be a read aloud, the
parents dragged their children
to come and attend, because
they heard in the announcement
reading, education,
mosque, religion.
This is great.
The children didn't
want to come of course,
but because we're very
obedient, they all came.
But when they come, I dress--
I bring funny stories
from their culture,
from their everyday life
in their native tongue.
And the children just fell
in love with the stories.
And then they line up
and take the books home.
And they started
becoming the champions
of reading within
their own homes,
begging their parents
to read to them
or themselves reading to
their peers or their siblings.
And so, a culture of
reading for pleasure
started to grow in
my neighborhood.
And the program, we
called it We Love Reading.
And it began to grow.
So we created a training program
for women, and then later men
as well.
And we started developing
our own stories
for children in Arabic.
And the program flourished
and spread, as Judy
said, now it's actually
35 countries and counting.
And we base all our
programming on research,
because I'm a scientist.
So we involved Yale
University, Harvard University,
Chicago University, and Brown.
And we did studies on different
aspects of the program
to make sure that what
we're doing is right
and how we can develop
it even better.
And I'm going to show you a
short video of We Love Reading
and how it has spread and has
been so effective, specifically
in refugee contexts.
Where the children are
in need of an education
program that they can engage
in, even if there is no school.
And where adults need a purpose
and agency in their lives.
Because in We Love Reading,
adults are all volunteers.
We don't pay them.
And they only do it
not because they do it
for me or for the
program, they actually
read aloud to the children
for their own good,
for their own community.
So it's sustainable
in that sense
and gives them
agency and ownership.
So enjoy.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
This is the Zaatari camp in
Jordan, the Syrian refugee
camp.
- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[END PLAYBACK]
- So this actual
video, the music for it
was made by a
Syrian composer who
used to be one of my students
when I was a teacher.
And so, the second scarf
is I was a teacher.
And that's my role.
And the third one, because I
forgot to talk about that one,
is that I'm a social
entrepreneur because
of We Love Reading.
So those are my third.
Now, meanwhile, I was actually--
I had a lab that I
was taking care of.
And I had research.
So what I did, I
established my lab.
And coming back to
Jordan from doing a PhD
and conducting research in
a high tech environment,
I had to find my own question.
And find my own research that
I could compete internationally
and produce good science
within the constraints,
whether it's funding
or bureaucracy that
existed in my country.
And I'm not alone.
This is in all
developing countries.
So I had to look around.
What is it that I could
give that's not found
in any other part of the world?
And at that time, the Human
HapMap project was coming out.
And deCODE, if people
aren't familiar with it,
it's an Icelandic company
that was coming out
doing genome-wide
association studies.
Discovering one gene after
another as novel risk
factors for diabetes, for
schizophrenia, for cancer
and so on.
So that started-- got me
thinking that in Jordan,
we actually have two ethnic
populations that emigrated from
southern Russia--
they are the Chechens
and the Circassians--
150 years ago, when they were
persecuted for their religion.
And they either fled or died
or were deported to Siberia.
So these two populations
actually came to Jordan
and settled in Jordan.
And they maintained
their isolation
by marrying only
within each other.
So I thought, I have a gold
treasure in my backyard.
So I started
collecting and doing
sweeps, studies
with anthropology,
epidemiology, and genetics
on these two populations.
And we created a DNA data bank.
And we became experts with those
two populations in the world,
because nobody else had
studied them so extensively.
And just because they've
been in Jordan for 150 years
is not enough to
change any genetics.
So the gene pool with them
is pretty homogeneous.
And last year, we got
a call from Berkeley,
from Rasmus Nielsen's lab--
who studies human
migration out of Africa--
asking us to contribute
and collaborate
with him with our
DNA, so that he
could add it to the pool of
DNA of humans migrating out
of Africa.
And we actually submitted
our work to nature.
We got the second round
review of reviewers,
which is very positive.
So we're excited
that we're going
to be publishing in
nature, although we're just
a small lab in Jordan with
the minimum resources.
But this is about asking
the right question
at the right time.
And then, because we
have this DNA data bank,
we started saying, what
other complex diseases
we could study in
these two populations?
So I chose to study
diabetes, because it
doesn't have a stigma
for an ethnic population.
And we actually discovered novel
genetic risk factors and copy
number variances in
these populations
that we just published
earlier this year.
And this led us that we wanted
to identify those genetic risk
factors in those populations.
We wanted to express them
in cells, in stem cells,
so that we can understand
what is their function
and how that contributes to
the mechanism of development
of diabetes.
However, to do that, we had
to deal with stem cells.
And that's when I
came back to Jordan,
after getting that
training on how
to do induced
pluripotent stem cells,
that I wanted to make sure
ethically that it's OK for me
to do that.
Or if I wanted to use
human embryonic stem cells.
And that's when we created
a committee in Jordan--
from theologians, scientists,
physicians lawyers--
to explore what is
allowed and what
is not allowed for research
and later, for therapy.
And we passed a law,
which was the first law
in the region that allowed us
to use human embryonic stem
cells up to the age
of five days, which
is enough to actually make a
human embryonic stem cell line.
So this was very
progressive for us,
considering the environment
that was going around.
Where in the states,
it wasn't allowed
for a certain period of
time or in other countries.
And lastly, because
as a scientist
we hold a responsibility
to our communities
and to our societies, with the
Syrian crisis spilling over
to Jordan and other
countries, I started thinking,
what can I do as a scientist
to help the people around us?
And so, I started
looking on, how
does the trauma affect
the children, the youth,
and the adults?
Does that affect only
physiological and mental
health?
And can it be transmitted
to other generations?
Which brought me into
the field of epigenetics.
And just to give you
briefly, epigenetics
is like something that happens
to you in your environment.
In this picture, it's
the mother smoking.
But you can imagine the trauma
of war compared to smoking.
And how that trauma
not just only
affects the body of
the individual who
is being exposed to
the trauma directly,
but it also affects
the fetus inside her.
And if that fetus is
a female, it actually
affects the reproductive
cells inside the fetus
inside the mother.
So the effects are
intergenerational.
And like my daughter
likes to remind me,
it's the immortal
kiss of grandparents
that affects us in the end.
So we hope that this research,
which is very new, where we're
comparing multiple
generations and looking
at the genetics and the
signature of the trauma
to help maybe develop programs
to help the children exposed
or their grandparents exposed.
So this, of course, this
is my fourth scarf, right?
I'm the scientist.
Now, the problems I faced
as a scientist in Jordan
were not specific
to me as a woman.
There was challenges that
affected everybody, male
and female.
And this is not just for Jordan,
for all developing countries.
Whether it's bureaucracy or
lack of funding, and so on.
So I actually I wrote
an article in Nature
two weeks ago as
an essay describing
the challenges that we
face in giving solutions.
That it's not about just the
resources inside our country,
many times it's also the
nations that actually
fund us or send us money.
Sometimes they send us the
money without understanding
what are the dynamics
inside the country.
And the solution is that
we need to sit together
on a table for us to describe
to them what our problems.
And for them to come up with
solutions or conditions,
as donors, to make things
happen more efficiently.
However, as a woman scientist,
I do experience challenges.
And these are not
unique to me in Jordan.
They are similar
to other challenges
that women face across
the world, even in the US.
And across careers,
not just as scientists.
As lawyers, as bankers,
as business people.
And I did two things
to address that.
One is I think that there are
many successful women that we
don't know about, we don't read
about, we don't learn about.
And if we brought those
to the forefront more,
by writing their stories, I
think more people will be aware
and more girls will be
encouraged to do science.
And more boys will respect
woman scientists or women
in other careers.
The second thing I did is I
developed a mentoring network.
And the reason I did it is
because as mothers, we do
our work because we enjoy it.
I enjoy my science very much.
But at the same time,
I enjoy my children.
So I don't have time for the
side talks, the coffee talk
to know what's going on.
What's the next
conference and so on.
So through this
mentoring network,
we paired females
together in a way
they would help each other
in a holistic approach,
both professionally
and personally.
And then we called it the
Three Circles of Alemat,
as you can see.
And alemat means female
scientist in Arabic.
So that speaks to the
history of the presence
of female scientists
throughout the years.
And we envisioned it as in this
cartoon, where seeds of pairs
actually help each other
to grow shoots and roots.
And then these shoots
and roots grow up
to be trees that produce new
seeds, and so on and so forth.
So it's like a cycle.
And this mentoring tool
kit that we developed
is already free online
for anybody to use it.
And it's not just for females.
Actually males can use it.
It's not just for scientists, it
could be for any walk of life.
And you could be a member
of any organization.
You could go take the
mentoring tool kit,
apply it within
your organization.
It's a step by step guide.
And because we wanted to
promote this all over the world,
we produced this video
as an inspiration
for female scientists
and mentoring.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- The world needs
us because we are
scientists, teachers, artists.
We are in all walks of life.
We are also the daughters,
the wives, the mothers.
And above all, we are humans.
Humans need to question
and be questioned,
to think, to share thoughts and
emotions, to spread knowledge.
We create networks to
experience moments,
a sense of
togetherness, and joy.
Three Circles of Alemat exists
because humans are determined
to make it into this world.
So shall we start?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
- Which brings me
to the second part
of my talk, which is the
main theme of the book
that I'm writing while
I'm here at Radcliffe.
And this actually starts
with another story, which
is a few years ago, I got an
email from an organization
based in Britain
called Muslim Science.
Where they had chosen 20 female
scientists from the Islamic
world-- which is
about 1.6 billion--
as female scientists who have
had an impact on the world.
And I was one of them.
And that was great,
thank you very much.
And I was scrolling down to
read the rest of the email
and they had given a
title for each one of us.
So the mathematician, the
cardiologist, the change-maker,
and things like that.
And as I was scrolling down
to find out what was my title,
I found out that my title
was the Islamic feminist.
And when they told me that,
when I read that, I said,
that's impossible.
Because when you say Islamic,
all the Western world
looks at you with suspicion.
And when you say feminist,
all the Eastern world
looks at you as suspicious.
And so, I lost on both accounts.
I emailed them, I
explained that to them.
They said, no, when you write--
I write a lot--
this is what you are.
And since then, I've been
trying to own the term,
own the identity, own
the title, redefine it.
Give it a new meaning
that fits with what I am.
And that's what made
me want to write a book
to explore what this is.
So that's actually the
fifth scarf, right?
They call me the
Islamic feminist.
I didn't want this.
I didn't work for it.
It was given to me.
So that's the way of life.
So I wanted to explore.
So the first thing that
I realized around me
as I was exploring, the
rhetoric around the world,
is that there are not enough
women in the workforce,
that half the population
is not being utilized,
that the economy
is being affected.
And if we had more
women in the workforce,
the economy would increased.
And we have all these
statistics showing
the different percentages
of females around the world.
But then I was reading a book.
And in this book,
I read an expert
who was very, very
interesting and moving
that I want to share with you.
And it's a very
nice story that I
hope you'll enjoy
as I read it to you.
Tomorrow, I will
do the unthinkable.
Once again, I will
pass over a newborn.
My heart will break.
I'm told to toughen up.
I'm reminded that I should be
thankful that I have a job.
Tomorrow morning, I will
race around the house
to ensure that I can do as much
as possible for my children
before leaving for work.
And despite the fact
that I am just one
of hundreds of thousands
of working mothers
who must do what they have
to do for their family,
my heart breaks as I know they
too are suffering and aching
for their baby.
Hard work?
I'm not afraid of that.
We are your typical
middle class family.
My husband and I
both have good jobs.
We work hard and we provide a
roof over our children's heads,
warm beds to sleep, and
full tummies every night.
Our children have
everything they need.
But if you ask what our children
want most, they'll tell you us.
They want their mommy.
Tomorrow, I will wipe away
tears, pull toddlers off
of my legs, unclench tiny little
fingers from around my neck,
and pass over a very new baby.
I will not be able
to kiss boo-boos that
happen throughout the day.
I will not be able to lay
babies down for their naps.
I will not be able to feed my
newborn when she cries for me.
Once again, I will have to try
to pretend mommy isn't hurting
or an emotional wreck inside.
And make my best attempt
to put on a brave
face for the sake of my babies.
But knowing myself, no matter
how courageous I strive to be,
undoubtfully tears will
stream down my face.
I have such trouble wrapping
my head around the thought
and accepting the fact
that my role as a mother
is not valued by society.
That I don't have the freedom
to decide what is important
and what is valued.
After I finished
reading that story,
I was reminded by a paragraph
from John Green's The Fault
in Our Stars.
I don't know if
you've read the book.
But in his book, he says,
sometimes you read a book
and it fills you with this
weird, evangelical zeal.
And you become convinced that
the shattered world will never
be put back again together
unless and until all living
humans read the book.
That's how I felt when
I read that excerpt.
And that's why I wanted
to share it with you.
And as John Green also said,
I'm on a roller coaster that
only goes up going from there.
So from there, I
started exploring.
And the first thing
I did is I wanted
to try to understand the
dilemma, where on one hand,
people were telling me there's
not enough room in the work
force, we need to
get more women in.
And on the other hand,
I read about this woman,
how she feels.
So what's right
and what's wrong?
And what should we
do as a society?
So that was my question
that I wanted to answer.
And at that point, I got
an Eisenhower fellowship.
And I used the
fellowship to actually
interview hundreds of women
from different cultures,
different backgrounds,
and different career paths
to try to understand,
unpack that question.
And I asked them a series of
questions, amongst which were,
what does success mean to you?
If you were a man, would you
choose the same career path?
And things like that.
And these will be the
essence of my book
that I'm writing
now at Radcliffe.
And so I'm going to give
you some of my results.
And I'm going to
focus on the science--
women in science more,
because that's my background.
But I think the results
and the findings
will be applicable to all
fields and all careers.
So if we look at women
in science similarly,
we have very low
numbers compared to men.
And this is all over the
world, as this data shows us.
Of course, it's gray for the US,
you don't have data for the US.
I wonder why.
I don't know.
So if you look at
the trajectory,
and this is reporting
for the Western world,
you see that the
percentages of males--
which is in blue as you go
through the education stage,
high school,
bachelor's degree, PhD,
and then research careers--
are the percentages of
males are also pretty high.
And then when you
go to the females,
the percentages
start going down.
And to me, the first thing
that comes to my mind
to explain this, which is
the first hypothesis-- so I
tried to address this issue
as a scientific problem,
as a scientist.
So I just want to
put a disclaimer here
that I'm not a
social scientist, I'm
not an education specialist.
I'm just coming at
this as a scientist,
thinking that this
really matters and I
have to do something about it.
I think as scientists,
we play sometimes roles
outside of our science, outside
of our labs and classrooms
that we owe to society.
Because I think society
is kind of already
bored from civic society
and from religious leaders
preaching.
And they're thirsty for a
different kind of role model
to look up to and to listen to.
And we know that our students
listen to us as scientists.
So we have something
that we can give.
So my first hypothesis
was, maybe we
don't have enough
women in the workforce
because women are
not educated enough.
And this is a lot of
rhetoric going around.
And in this graph here, it seems
that women are not educated
enough, as you can see.
Because the percentages
are like 32% and then
25% in a PhD level.
But when I look in
Jordan, I found out
that the statistics
are very different.
In Jordan, we have 64%
female in bachelor's degree.
And actually, in biology,
my class has 90% females.
Pharmacy, it's almost
90% females as well.
And if we go to the
master's degrees, 57%.
PhD, it's 56%.
So apparently it's
not about education
if in Jordan, where we even have
less women in the workforce,
we have more educated women.
So I crossed out that hypothesis
applying the scientific method.
And I drew my line, which is
the red line, where, no, we're
highly educated as females.
And that could not be the
reason or the prime reason
that we have less
women in the workforce.
So the second hypothesis
is, oh, maybe the workforce
is not comfortable and
flexible for women.
I don't know if
I'm ruining this.
I'm going to take
these off, sorry.
And yes, we have less women in
the workforce also in Jordan.
And this is some data showing
that we have 23% female
in research careers in Jordan.
But this hypothesis
didn't hold up either.
Because McKinsey has been
producing report after report
showing that even after
you introduce measures
in the workplace to make it more
easier and flexible for women,
such as nurseries or flexible
hours or a little bit more
extended maternity leave--
not much in the US--
still the percentages
of women remain low.
So that crossed out
my second hypothesis.
And I started thinking,
wait a minute.
As a scientist,
you ask yourself,
you keep questioning yourself.
Maybe I'm asking the
wrong question, right?
Maybe it's not, how can we get
more women in the workforce?
And what I came up with
is a paradigm shift.
Rather than asking how to get
more women into the workforce,
we should be asking, what
do women really want?
How do women define success?
Did anybody ask
us what we really
wanted before
going around saying
we have to have more
women in the workforce?
So I think this is an
innovative approach.
And I started trying
to find evidence
for that approach, again
as a third hypothesis.
So I start from looking at
men and women in the West.
So there's a fight for
equality in the West
that we all are familiar with,
which started with feminism
in the last century.
It was always about women
wanting to be equal to men.
If a man drives a truck,
I want to drive a truck.
If a man carries a bag of
flour that's very heavy,
I'm going to do that.
We're equal.
And we were trying to fit
into one mold of success,
into one definition.
Which is this framework,
this very crude,
vulgar framework of
what success means
that was defined by
men in the workforce.
So we were trying
to fit into that.
And there was only one.
To the extent that we were
denying ourselves who we
are as females, biologically.
And I'm sure many of you heard
how Facebook and Google offered
to freeze eggs for women till
they were over the age of 40.
To me, that's making me
more fit into that mold,
into that definition.
And the consequences
of such actions
were, well, you still had
less females in the workforce.
That didn't improve.
And those who were
were struggling always,
similar to the story
I just read you.
And many just didn't get
married or didn't have children,
because we only had
one framework, which
was made by men for men.
And also, if a woman
stayed at home or chose to,
she was frowned upon.
And if you acted
as a mom at work,
you were not serious enough.
Now that's fine, if it
stayed in one country.
The problem is it was being
exported all over the world.
And that's when I felt
the problem, right?
There's something going wrong
when my students started
talking about such things.
Especially when
we look at my part
of the world in our rich
civilization and history,
where actually we had
Fatima al-Fihri, who
built the first university
in 1859, which is still
existing today in Morocco.
While in 1821, we know
that females in Britain--
I mean, people questioned
if they had a soul.
They were not allowed
to be educated.
They weren't allowed to
have their own ownership
and their own
property, when we had
those luxuries and privileges
1,000 years before.
So with this importation
to other countries,
this was oppression
at a grand scale.
Not to say that we
have our problems
in my part of the world.
I mean, people have forgotten
what Islam really means
and we see the
consequences around us.
But we were getting a double
oppression, the oppression
from not understanding our
religion properly and being
oppressed because of tribalism.
And then oppression
by importing ideas
from the West that didn't
quite fit who we are.
So I wanted to approach
this as a biologist.
So I said, look, let's look at
the evolution of the species.
We evolved as a species
to have male and female.
And each one, I mean, we're
both the same species.
We're all human, homo sapiens.
But we evolved to have slightly
different roles, right?
So as a female, I evolved
to, I have a womb.
I'm going to carry the fetus.
I'm going to nurse,
breastfeed this child.
The man doesn't do that.
The male part of my
species doesn't do that.
So I envisioned if
we have differences
physiologically, I'm assuming
we should have some differences
in how we define success.
And I envision this that
our definition of success
will be as diverse and as
colorful as the ceiling.
Anybody knows what
the ceiling is?
Yes, the Familia in Barcelona,
as beautiful as that
and as diverse as that
and as diverse as our DNA.
And so, we may come
up with a range
of definitions of success,
what it means to us as females.
Whether it's how senior we are
and how much money we earn,
which is more similar to
what men define as success,
or success to us could be
just enjoying having a child
and bringing up the
next generation.
And anything in between.
And we don't have
to stick to one.
It could be a zigzag.
We go in and out.
We change.
Our priorities change with
different times in our lives,
with different environments,
with different needs.
So we could have our
definition of success
is having a child at one stage.
And then in another
stage, it's no,
I want to be the best scientist
in my field, and so on.
Actually, this graph
comes from a study
that was done by MIT, where
they compared male graduates
to female graduates.
And they followed them
in their career paths.
And I don't know if you can
guess which ones is the male.
The male are the ones
that went up on a tangent,
but then they
plateaued at age 40.
That was it.
But for females, it was
zigzag and they kept going up.
And so, this speaks
to the skills
that a woman gains
through her life
by taking care of
her family, that she
keeps on going if she
trusts herself enough
and community does.
And also, there's an added
component of social compassion
that females have, that
pushes them to do more
and to choose those fields where
she feels she has an impact.
Not to say that this
will not benefit men.
Not every man wants to be the
highest earner and the leader.
Many men also want to have
new definitions of success.
So this is not just for
females, by the way.
This will benefit
all humans, for them
to identify what they want and
what they consider successful.
Now, this becomes
very important when
I'm talking about valuing
other than just leadership
positions and career paths.
When I say that,
we need to value
our children and the upbringing
of our children as a role
that females and
males should play
in the lives of their children.
Especially in the
first five years.
So there's a lot
of data coming out
showing that the child's
brain as it develops,
those neurons, they create
connections with each other.
And these connections,
if you don't use them,
you're going to lose them.
And how do you use them?
It's by interacting with
the environment around you.
And when a child interacts
with the environment around him
or her, it's not just about food
and shelter and cleanliness.
It's about the
social interaction.
And what's better a
social interaction
than with the mother and the
father, the biological mother
and father who actually
brought them up,
who is going to give
them the full attention?
And any neglect,
however slight, will
have an effect on our children.
And this is an example
of two brains, where
one is a normal one with parents
who are around and taking
care of the child.
And another one, the second
one, is of extreme neglect.
And we have examples from
the Romanian orphanage--
I don't know if you've heard
about it-- where children were
given everything they need
in terms of shelter and food
and cleanliness, but there
was no social interaction
whatsoever.
And these children grew up to
have extreme social problems,
even mental problems as well.
So what is more important than
to spend those important years
of our children's lives where
the mother and the father
are there with them?
And nobody can
substitute a parent,
but anybody can
substitute you at work.
And work can wait until you
bring up the next generation.
So how do we solve this?
So all the people I've
interviewed tell me, yeah,
we agree with you.
But what do we do?
Well, I mean, first is that
we need to know ourselves.
We need to feel comfortable
with who we are.
We need to know our identities.
And then we need to educate
ourselves and read and learn,
so that we know what are
the options in front of us
when we give the decision
to our young generation
to decide what
success means to them.
We need them to
find their passion.
And then, after they find
their passion, to pursue it.
To teach them the
entrepreneurial skills so
that they can
pursue that passion.
And this becomes
even more relevant
in a world of underemployment.
I mean, whether in
the US or in Jordan
or in many parts of the world,
unemployment is on the rise.
And there's not enough jobs.
So when you become
an entrepreneur,
you're actually
creating new jobs.
So this is something
that's very much needed
and gives you the opportunity
to explore that new field.
But most importantly--
after you know who you are,
you educate yourself,
you find your passion,
and you have the
skills to pursue it--
most importantly,
society should give us
the freedom to choose
what we want to be,
whether it's men or women.
And I think it's
oppression if I tell women,
you have to go to work.
And it's oppression
if I tell women,
you have to stay at home.
It's about trusting her
to choose what she wants,
because she knows better.
And of course, here I
am talking about what
women should choose as success
from a platform of privilege.
All of us are privileged here.
Because I speak and think of
all the women refugees around
the world-- whether it's in
Syria or Palestine or Myanmar
or Yemen--
who don't have the
opportunities we have.
And don't have the choices.
They're not grappling with
these choices that we are.
But in order to help them,
we have to help start
helping ourselves.
And change takes a long time.
The road of a million
miles starts with a small--
or the first step.
And we should
always start small.
Because a lot of
people don't do things,
they think they have to
change the world first
or it has to be huge or big.
No, you can start from
your own neighborhood,
from your own community,
your own family, yourself.
And I like to compare this to
the physics theory, the chaos
theory.
When a butterfly flutters
its wings in China,
there's a hurricane
in the Atlantic.
So whatever good you do or
whatever effort you try,
it will have an impact
sometime, someplace.
And everybody's waiting.
Everybody's thirsty for
change and innovation.
And I always like to end with
Dr. Seuss, Oh, the Places
You'll Go.
I'm sure you've read
the book many times.
And in the last page, he
says, and will you succeed?
Yes, he answers,
you will indeed.
98 and 3/4 percent guaranteed,
kid, you'll move mountains.
And I'm going to end with
this one minute video.
You know, they tell
you words are better--
pictures are better than words.
And movies are
better than pictures.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
So don't wait.
Yeah, just jump
in, be innovative.
Don't care what other people
tell you or comment on you.
So that's the end of my story.
And I urge you
during the reception
to draw what success
means to you.
So we have some crayons
and some paper out there.
And if you could add on-- you
don't have to put your name.
But if you tell us
where you're from,
your age range, roughly,
and your career, so we
can maybe make an
exhibit next year
at Radcliffe of
what success means
from different perspectives.
And that leads me to part
three, the unanswered questions.
Which would be your
role, to ask questions
and to challenge me,
because I'm here to learn
and to listen and together
to make a difference.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]